martin je le sens que ça va arriver
cette affaire non ici on nous disait
pareil moi je te dis je sens que ça va
arriver on va voir faire vacciner les
enfants que c'est une question pensent à
moi je suis totalement contre je vois
pas je vois pas l'intérêt en fête avec
les enfants les pda disent que dans
l'intérêt des enfants il n'y a pas et a
pas de bénéfices et après dans l'intérêt
des autres j'ai mes équipes ont
travaillé là dessus et vacciner les
enfants n'empêchera pas la circulation
du virus dans le reste de la population
qui circule très bien dans les adultes
particulièrement chez les jeunes qui
sont très sociabiliser donc les enfants
il n'y a pas lieu de les vacciner que
certains parents veuillent les vaccinés
oui mais le rendre obligatoire ça peut
pas ça peut pas supporter la nation des
films étaient bien tous vos pancartes
faites un tour garde alors mythe et
bientôt de port cartier vous vous mettez
bien aller bien vite en garde le regard
des
cartes non maintenant dit je vois pas je
vois pas l'intérêt de faire vacciner les
enfants moi je veux pas faire du
complotisme de bas étage mais
effectivement on est en droit de se
poser la question quand on sait que les
enfants attrapent pas ou peu le vide qui
ne meurt tragiquement pas du coup vite
quel serait l'intérêt d'obliger de faire
un forcing pour vacciner tous les
enfants à part d'enrichir les
laboratoires qui rappelons le gagne 1000
euros par seconde avec le co vite je
pense que la question elle mérite d'être
posée sans qu'on soit acceptable
autistes fabrice
aux problèmes dans le mauvais sens
[Rires]
j'aurais également pas perdre et dire
que la question est pour rien
[Rires]
la question voilà alors pas dit pourquoi
on en fait la question qui se pose c'est
est-ce que ça a un intérêt de vacciner
les enfants tout court la réponse est
non ça n'a aucun intérêt si aujourd'hui
on vous parle d'un regain
d'hospitalisation moi j'ai regardé un
petit peu et en effet il y à un regain
de spéculation des enfants ayant un
regard de faim critique des enfants mais
vous savez pourquoi parce qu'en fait
l'année dernière la bronchiolite ne
circulaient pas et que cette année
effectivement nous sommes revenus à des
niveaux qui sont soudés 2019 2019 a bien
tourné inintéressante polémique 19 on
disait intéresse à cause de la
bronchiolite on est passé à côté de la
catastrophe sanitaire en réanimation des
enfants donc nous avons un problème
structurel aujourd'hui particulièrement
en ile de france au niveau des soins
nous avons un problème de places
d'hôpital on gère cette épidémie pardon
mais comme de la merde oui elle est là
la vérité sorte et qu'on n'a pas voulu
investir dans ce qu'il fallait investir
c'est à dire l'hôpital est donc
aujourd'hui on est en train d'épuiser
les soignants épuisé les citoyens et on
va à la guerre civile si tout continue
pascal vaccination des enfants que ce
soit bien clair mais alors qu'est ce qui
va se passer eh ben les gens vont
désormais lire points et on pourra pas
les en blâmer les gens vont désobéi
c'est n'importe quoi cette histoire
alors docteur afin d'apporter ses
docteurs jfk vous appelez réagi rémy
saha étudiants en pharmacie avec steam
vous êtes pour la vaccination des
enfants alors oui je suis pour la
vaccination des enfants parce que déjà
si on peut regarder les chiffres par
rapport à hier le 13 janvier on a quatre
cent dix huit hospitalisations 74
personnes en réanimation alors ok quatre
décès depuis le début de la semaine
pourquoi de quoi des adultes
au logis en arrivant parce que vous avez
une étude vous avez eu étude qui préside
la vaccination des enfants pas de
matelas l'étude européenne qui préside
la vaccination des enfants est ce que
vous avez lu l'étude qui explique
pourquoi est-ce que la vaccination des
enfants peut avoir un intérêt est ce que
vous souvenez pourquoi moi je pense tout
d'abord qui a un intérêt personnel non
mais vous savez pourquoi non
alors je vais vous dire pourquoi rythme
parce qu'on considérait à l'époque que
le variant delta et bien empêcher la
transmission en fait c'est que c'est
écrit noir sur blanc dans le centre
européen de prévention des maladies
infectieuses et l'étude ou dit si jamais
il ya un autre variant est bas alors il
faudra revoir fabre et le principe le
delta est toujours là actuellement il
est un peu là mais aujourd'hui on sait
qu effectivement derrière majoritaire
on sait alors le delta est toujours là
et je pense que surtout avec au micro
les choses ont beaucoup changé et sont
d'autant plus grave parce que il faut
déjà cherché à protéger l'enfant d'un
point de vue intérêt mais ça protège
comment laissez moi juste un massacre au
teich comme en mai ce que fait le vaccin
et le vaccin permet de protéger
justement les enfants mais protégé de
quoi
commencer la démographie c'est ça la
question c'est ça qu'on veut savoir déjà
il ya le débat est ce que il faut
vacciner ses enfants qui ne sont pas à
risque mais s'il ya des enfants à risque
forcément mais voilà oui j'en ai comme
arbitres y voilà oui oui mais non médias
on peut les enfants à risque les enfants
à risque sont déjà vaccinés
soit que ça fait longtemps de là mais
voilà les ont baptisées tous les enfants
rient ça c'est sûr non c'est pourquoi il
faut vacciner c'est quoi cette histoire
vacciner non il faut par exemple
parisien non mais attendez les gars
vous raconter n'importe quoi sur ce coup
là quel est le risque et quel est le
risque du vaccin versus effectivement
vous savez de quoi vous parlez ou jamais
vous l'avez
il pas d'homme quand tu vois le
risque
est ce que est ce que oui ou non il y en
a un dans cette pièce qu'à lui l'étude
qui préside la vaccination des enfants
oui oui oui là louis martin non d'accord
ok avoir lu ok mais finalement on me
déçoit
c'est qu'en fait aujourd'hui ce qu'on
vous explique effectivement c'est qu'on
n'a aucune idée des prix de vaccination
soit les enfants les enfants à risque on
ne sait pas si la vaccination à
bénéfices sur eux je vous le dis c'est
écrit noir sur blanc dans l'étude ma
femme voulait pas lui l'étude quels lots
la linguère est révisé de mai vous lisez
pas l'étude à caudry que c'est par la
flambée du yen est à l'étude il a 16 ans
et support oui moi je suis ni province
ni anti vague je suis rien du tout moi
je j'essaye de par contre j'ai une mère
de famille une mère de famille je savais
faire confiance donc je veux bien faire
un pas vers la médecine on nous dit
quand même fabrice je pense sans aide
trovax que des formes graves sont évités
chez des adultes qui ont des
comorbidités et c'est donc là on parle
des adultes pourquoi est ce qu'avec ce
raisonnement là on dirait pas que des
formes graves peuvent être évitées
jeunes enfants qui ont des comores bla
je vais vous les fans de moncton mais
bon c'est pas tout ça immunodéprimés je
vais vous répondre à cause de l'absence
de parallélisme clinique quoi il n'y a
aucun parallélisme clinique entre
l'enfant et à vue c'est pour ça que les
études de médicaments sont faites sur
les adultes et qu'on a un gros problème
en pédiatrie elles ne sont pas faites
sur les enfants et que sa route
et
que ça pose toujours un problème c'est
qu'actuellement l'étude pfizer sur les
enfants est pourri il faut être
parfaitement clair ensuite effectivement
le centre européen de prévention des
maladies infectieuses lui même vous
explique que l'un dans l'autre il n'ya
pas de bénéfices réels à la vaccination
des enfants et ça donc piqué ses enfants
non nés sans absolument anormal c'est
une question parce que notre raison
d'être c'est qu'effectivement on n'a pas
d'idée ce l'efficacité bon dans
l'attende la vaccination tandis qu'on
n'a pas d'efficacité on a pas de notion
non plus du risque pour les enfants
puisqu'on a des problèmes de cohorte
veut dire le problème vous savez alors
bien sûr martin on va parler du
parallélisme critiques après évidemment
que quand un vaccin fonctionne chez les
adultes ya quand même de bonnes chances
qui fonctionne sur les enfants quand
même un petit parallélisme et on l'a
déjà évoqué mais moi j'aime les frites
mes enfants aussi beau donc ça c'est un
premier point le deuxième point c'est
vrai non mais c'est vrai que par contre
la plupart des enfants que ceux
hospitalisés ils ont moins de deux ans
et ça vous pouvez demander pda très vous
le diront ils sont pas dans la tranche
des vagues des enfants pour vacciner ces
5 et 11 ans - c'est même un point un
petit peu important à ce que je veux
dire qu'aujourd'hui les enfants qu'on
cite pour dire qu'il faut vacciner les
enfants sont pas ceux qui pour la
tranche d'âge et à l'indicatif finale
des enfants ça oui c'est maria aussi
beaucoup de nourrissons on oublie en
fait ici mais socialement de gérer son
deuil
c'est que c'est souvent des nourrissons
qui sont hospitalisés et qu'ils peuvent
avoir avec un autre virus infecte et ça
s'était montrée données américaines tout
ça c'est à dire que le risque qu vite
chez les enfants en tout cas les 5-11
ans est extrêmement faible bien plus
faible que la plupart des vies rose
hivernale donc on peut pas dire que le
risque au vide sur les enfants ayant
très importante en carrousel choses
aurait été que ça ne protégera pas les
adultes